aujourd'hui j'ai j'ai en gros étaient le
héros de mes frères aujourd'hui
aux yeux de la justice je deviens
l'auteur des violences parce que j'ai
défendu mon petit frère de 16 ans quand
trois personnes adultes on poursuit
aujourd'hui pour violence volontaire en
réunion aujourd'hui après tout ce que
mes parents ils ont fait à mes frères et
sœurs à moi-même
ils sont en liberté ils font 48 heures
de garde à vue on les relâche avec un
contrôle judiciaire
donc là dans un an dans leur donne
encore la possibilité de reprendre les
enfants
si tout se passe bien si est respecté
leurs obligations j'ai aimé frère et
sœur j'ai aucune nouvelle aujourd'hui on
m'interdit de rentrer en contact avec
eux
par peur que je l'ai aimé dans une forme
de vengeance envers mes parents
j'ai toujours appelé en un non violence
envers mes parents elle a non vengeance
je veux aujourd'hui que la justice
m'aide aujourd'hui la justice se
retourne contre moi
là la policière là
l'aspectrice m'a clairement dit que pour
elle il y avait pire elle a déjà vu pire
aujourd'hui je comprends pas comment
comment en France un enfant qui vient
défendre ses frères et sœurs
puissent aujourd'hui se retourner sur le
bord des accusés et vous avez défendu
contre qui complètement mon père ma sœur
il y avait des des services qui durent
depuis des années des années et un jour
voilà Brian il y avait son son père qui
qui était d'ailleurs avec sa sœur une
bagarre qui ont violenté son son petit
frère 16 ans il a il a pris part à la
bagarre et aujourd'hui tu es donc
poursuivi pour ça c'est ça et
aujourd'hui il y a aussi tous les
membres de la famille qu'ils ont pas
malheureusement et être familial le site
ce qui a mis qu'ils ont voulu parler aux
médias pour faire en gros entendre à la
justice ce qui s'est passé car on a vite
bâclé l'affaire
on entend deux trois personnes c'est
juger au mois de janvier
accusé d'être donnant l'assistance à
personne donc alors monsieur le ministre
c'est le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin qu'on lui pose beaucoup de
questions
en tout cas ça nous a je sais tous
beaucoup choqué moi je suis de votre
région c'est une note de notre région du
Nord-Pas-de-Calais j'ai vu ça
je pense que ça a vraiment rempli des
froids plein de gens
au ministère
au gouvernement pardon je commence un
peu à fatiguer moi aussi il y a une
secrétaire d'État le président de la
République a voulu avant c'était Adrien
taquet maintenant c'est Charlotte cobel
qui s'occupe spécialement de l'enfance
et qui s'est intéresse beaucoup si je
veux dire à votre très malheureuse
histoire d'ailleurs elle s'est rendue
dans votre département avec le président
du département du Pas-de-Calais puisque
c'est lui qui a la compétence de
s'occuper de l'enfant et moi ce que je
vous propose monsieur c'est peut-être de
la rencontrer elle et sauf que par
ailleurs dans sa vie civile elle est
magistrate son travail elle c'est d'être
magistrates donc elle pourra à la fois
vous écouter vous entendre elle pourra
pas intervenir dans le dossier vous
comprenez bien ça c'est l'histoire entre
avocat et juge mais on peut pas rentrer
dans ce dossier mais moi je vous propose
si on est d'accord de la rencontrer très
très vite peut-être demain ou lundi si
vous êtes disponible
dans laquelle vous explique que vous
entendiez qu'elle va entendre votre
histoire qu'elle voit comment elle peut
vous aider et puis qu'elle vous donne
des conseils aussi
j'avoue que bon voilà c'est vrai que
c'est pas une compétence bien sûr par
contre ce qui on en parlera tout à
l'heure peut-être en dehors de
l'émission les policiers ils ont pas à
faire de ce genre de constat c'est pas
voilà donc je serai heureux d'entendre
tout à l'heure ce que vous avez à me
dire merci en tout cas merci
le ministre donc je suis la compagne de
Brian
moi j'avais une question qui me touche
c'est comment on peut accuser mon
conjoint qui risque de finir en prison
et ne pas vouloir leur donner les
enfants
excusez-moi
bah ça madame malheureusement quand on
accuse quelqu'un on a un droit de le
faire si j'ose dire et après il faut
qu'il se défendent et c'est pour ça
qu'elle procédure c'est pour entendre le
contradictoire et
la justice est faite ainsi que les
arguments de votre conjoint sont très
entendu et à la fin le juge il va
prendre en considération la situation
dans laquelle vous étiez donc
l'accusation c'est évidemment pas une
culpabilité c'est d'ailleurs pour la
question qu'on posait pour d'autres
histoires il faut accepter malgré
l'émotion malgré les grandes énervements
aux colères qu'on peut avoir quand on
est soi-même accusé ou quand on accuse
quelqu'un faut accepter que le temps de
la justice
écoute tout le monde que les policiers
enfin centrale d'enquêteurs ils vont
entendre j'imagine que Madame pourrait
vous expliquer qu'ils vont entendre
beaucoup de retour de vous c'est pour ça
qu'avec un contrôle judiciaire pour
quelque chose qui nous écoutent
comprennent que le contrôle judiciaire
c'est qu'on lui a demandé de faire un
syndrome de choses qu'elle doit
respecter j'imaginais et voilà qui doit
pas influencer des témoins et à la fin
des fois cette accusation bah ce sera
classé on considère qu'il y a un
non-lieu mais c'est pendant ce temps-là
vous vivez avec cette accusation il y a
beaucoup de Français qui vivent dans la
situation et personne ne peut
restreindre j'ai dit moi-même tout à
l'heure que je pouvais pas refuser un
policier de prendre une plainte et donc
je veux pas me contrarier en disant
toute personne qui veut déposer plainte
doit le faire mais toute personne qui
dépose une plainte n'a pas l'assurance
de la d'obtenir la condamnation c'est il
y a une procédure et ça vous arrivera
peut-être de déposer plainte ça vous
arrivera peut-être à accusé c'est
extrêmement difficile mais le temps de
la justice est fait pour être respecté
pour accepter ce qu'on traducteur d'eau
je comprends votre émotion mais je peux
en état de droit à une démocratie n'est
pas empêché personne de déposer plainte